Vladimir's wife Jeff Guinea Cara mertza
thank you so much for for joining us and
finding finding the time at what must be
an incredibly challenging time for you
and and my first question is just you
know how are you holding up
well I don't have um many choices do I
um
thank you very much for giving me this
platform
uh
I am holding up because I am married to
an incredible man I know that
I have he has my utmost respect and
admiration and I will fight for him for
as long as it takes
I will fight for my kids father and I
will make everything I can to bring him
home to them
when you heard the length of the
sentence 25 years
were you shocked and surprised or had
you consciously or subconsciously
started to come to expect that that it
might be that severe
um no actually unfortunately I was not
surprised at all because uh when asking
for this absolutely mind-boggling
a sentence a quarter of a century
um the prosecutor in my in my husband's
case said and I quote this is our enemy
who must be punished in a very
soviet-style wording um but it also made
me not this made me realize of course it
was obvious before that the current
Russian government since sees Vladimir
as its personal enemy for his uh long
time work on behalf of Russian Civil
Society for his uh campaigning for the
introduction of targeted sanctions
against human rights violators who stole
in Russia but hid that money in the west
um for all his long-time uh denouncing
of the crimes committed by this regime
with regard to its own population and
with regard to our closest neighbors for
all of that my husband is portrayed by
the government by the current Russian
government as a Trader
and uh this is why I realized that um
seen as a um as an enemy of the state is
seen as a personal enemy uh he needs to
be locked up for a quarter of a century
to stop him from continuing his work
and I I wonder however right or wrong
that is knowing as you do now how things
have played out do you wish he never did
return to Russia or are you still
despite this extreme punishment proud
that he did
uh well I don't think that this is the
the right question to ask because he
never left Russia he refused to leave
his country he is a true Russian Patriot
so uh had I asked him to give up his
spice
uh
I could not have done it I know what my
husband is fighting for I know how
important it is to him and to many
Russians to see a different Russia I
know that he believes
we deserve better
and I completely agree with him and I
share his conviction that this is
possible a different Russia is possible
it's just that we need to work to do
everything we can to bring closer the
day that this regime collapses and we
get a chance at building that different
Russia because for as long as there is
an author retire in a totalitarian
regime in our country Russia will
continue being a threat to itself and
its neighbors
so the only way for Russia to stop being
a threat to everyone is for it to become
a democracy and in order for that to
happen first Putin's vertical of power
needs to collapse so I I cannot
um I know what my husband is fighting
for and believe me I am terrified for
his life and uh I know that our kids are
terrified for their father
um but I understand what he's fighting
for and I will do everything I can to
raise awareness about what is happening
in Russia in the context of this war of
aggression against Ukraine I want to do
everything I can to show the world to
the world that there is a very close
connection between internal repression
and external aggression they go hand in
hand there are two sides of the same
coin and in order to continue warmong in
Vladimir Putin needs to stifle descent
to completely eradicate all descent
within our country and many people are
in in Russia are suffering from
repression from the extreme level of
repression that is now being
um used against the Russian population
and and obviously uh President Putin is
quite successful at uh at stymie debate
at stopping critics from from speaking
out I I wonder uh how optimistic you are
that your husband's cause uh his fight
is working do you think his message is
reaching the majority of Russians do you
think that there is a swell of opinion
that that share his fight your fight or
or are you fearful that you're still
early days in in what will be a long
battle
when we talk about uh
we
we are obviously talking talking about
an unhealthy Society but at the same
time I think we need to realize that the
last time the Russian population had
access to free and independent well
actually it was free but not fair
election according to International
organizations it was held in 2003 that's
over two decades of stolen elections
also the last major independent TV
channel readily available to the
majority of the Russian population was
closed down by the authorities in 2003
as well so that's over two decades of
propaganda the Russian population has
does not have a single Democratic
instrument of voicing descent there is
no freedom of speech there is no freedom
of Association no freedom of assembly no
free and fair elections
every single right and freedom has been
taken from the Russian population so uh
in this presence of total propaganda it
is extremely difficult to reach the
majority of the population with
independent news as you might imagine
but at the same time Russia placed
second by the number of VPN Services
installed last year second worldwide
which shows that there is a very high
demand for independent and objective
information to access uh to independent
and objective information this is why it
is so important to support the work of
independent journalists working both
inside and outside of Russia creating
this independent content for the
russian-speaking population so I I uh I
believe that it is not just you know
we're not talking about optimism here
we're talking about what we can do to
bring closer the day when this regime
collapses and I believe that everyone
who has an opportunity to do something
should do it whether it's uh spreading
objective information whether it's uh
supporting the work of journalists
whether it's supporting the work of
Human Rights activists lawyers who
represent those who are being oppressed
in Russia uh those who can call for more
support to Ukraine because uh Ukraine's
victory in this war on Ukraine's terms
is crucial in that this will weaken the
regime in the Kremlin and this will of
course bring uh bring closer the
downfall of the regime everything has to
be done now to weaken the regime and
create
um conditions for the Russian population
to realize that they can actually change
something and that will see Mass
protests in the streets of Russian
cities I I wonder in light of that if
you mind me asking for your viewer about
the Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gershkovich who's who's been arrested
and denied a bail pending trial just uh
just today what's your view of that what
do you think Russia's motivation is of
that and and do you think it's a warning
sign to to All Foreign journalists uh in
Russia and and should they take heed of
what's happened to gershowitz and and
potentially leave the country or is it
important they stay
well the rest of evangeshkovic of course
um angered me a lot and saddened me at
the same time I understand that this is
an attack against free press against
freedom of speech absolutely and you're
absolutely right in saying that this is
a signal to all those journalists who
still remain in the country who refused
to live like Vladimir refused to live
because they believe it is their duty to
stay and report from the grounds and
they're doing an extremely courageous
work now and I am truly very grateful to
every single journalist who still
remains in Russia and reports about the
situation uh with uh with the situation
with human rights in Russia reports from
the ground I am truly
um I admire these people's courage and I
understand that um after the blockade of
all independent Russian media in the
country over 200 000 online media
resources have been blocked since uh
February 2022
um all remaining Russian independent
major Independent Media TV novega
theater and echo of Moscow radio station
have all been closed down by the
authorities after the full-scale
invasion had broken out and access to
social media platforms has been blocked
as well so the regime is doing
everything to isolate the Russian
population from any kind of independent
information they're doing everything
from if or isolating the world from
knowing what's happening in the country
because Vladimir Putin depends a lot on
creating this warped Imaging of reality
for the world that the Russian
population the entire Russian population
stands behind him and the war and
supports his policies in order to
achieve that he of course needs to
stifle all Independent Media who say
otherwise
I I wanted to come back uh whether it's
Evan we're talking about it or more
importantly uh with your point of view
your husband to to touch on something I
I know you've talked about before but
whether or not the US I know you're
us-based the UK your husband was a dual
National are doing enough in your eyes
uh and and I guess I I cover this with
the perspective that clearly both
countries are supporting Ukraine in a
war against Russia and that comes with
its own uh significant political
challenges domestically as recent leaks
uh intelligence leaks have highlighted
are you disappointed that they're not
doing more or can you understand the
difficult balancing act that they face
as governments
um I'm sure that
sure that there was this
when Western leaders had to deal with
the Soviet regime and yet uh thanks to
the efforts the personal advocacy of
Western leaders many Soviet dissidents
were freed during the Soviet times uh
Andrei Sakura was allowed to return from
his Exile in Gorky
um Vladimir bukowsky was released Natan
shironsky was allowed to leave the
country uh
Oleg or love
Ginsburg and other Soviet dissidents
were released thanks to the advocacy of
Western leaders so I believe that if it
was possible during the Soviet times it
is definitely possible now and also I
believe that the the entire Democratic
Community should stand with those people
who risk their lives and their freedom
to protect the same values on which the
Democratic societies are built they are
fighting for the same freedoms for their
countries and I believe that it would be
very symbolically strong for the
Democratic countries for the Democratic
Community to spend these people and
fight for their release thank you so
much for your time this evening we
greatly appreciate it we're right up
against the top of the clock